vous êtes un soleil vous est une
merveille et si au tous les deux nous
irons benjamin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
messmer à ce qu'on pouvait nous
expliquer comment est ce que vous avez
fait avec les quelques minutes que j'ai
eus je lui ai fait accroire que son
téléphone c'était sa chaussure plaisir
au téléphone rouge
pourquoi ça sonne vous entendez
quelqu'un c'est la seconde fois que la
chausseria si on aura une immense star
grâce à vous oui assurent ces bateaux
vous allez voir dans un instant il y
aura et je vous le dis johnny hallyday
on sent le plateau de tous
[Applaudissements]
sarah johnny ça
c'est comme la chanson vous préférez
votre répertoire johnny hallyday vient
beaucoup mais qui connaît peut-être dans
l'obscurité
puis la lumière oui comme nana la faim
la soif fusa festin choral et vous ceux
qui y va et secondaires que je retrouve
le prix la vie enfin la salle audio
dolby et loris braun oui avec moi c'est
toute ma vie c'est tout rôti laëtitia
est ce que vous avez envie de la voir ce
soir j'ai guidé par l'autre vérité a pas
longtemps oui et bien laëtitia est avec
nous sur le plateau ce soir laetitia
giry haye et personnels douce aux
quelques goodies de trois choses à
proposer d'ici laetitia c'est la plus
belle rencontre de ma vie c'est celle
qui va inspirer c'est surtout celle qui
m'a donné peut-être les plus importants
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est quoi mes
enfants très content d'être là jean ça
va
mais qu'est-ce que vous êtes bourne vous
êtes magnifique vous je sais qu'il ya
votre animateur préféré ses bazars
nakatani voulez mais lui je t'aime
[Musique]
2 me
vous êtes un soleil vous est une
merveille et si au tous les deux nous
irons d'un jamin loin bien loin
benjamin je vous aime maintenant je vais
changer de personnalité
je vais changer sa personnalité l'accord
gilles vous êtes cyril hanouna a dit
fais ta chronique
ok l'apprenti chronique mais a bien sûr
déjà la chronique et bas cet aprem je
sais pas si ça vous intéresse ou pas non
non les petits beauté on y va là
illusion
les chaînes chawal à la télé
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]